[Musique]
qu'ils soient faux
geste
mais qui reste je crois pas que tu as
fait un peu beaucoup la chine mais on
veut aller au bar
bienvenue à dos
oui là-bas
je
[Musique]
suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le qatar un pays à peine plus grand que
la corse 724 mille habitants 20 % de cas
paris tous les autres sont des étrangers
coface est il il y à 60 ans les qatari
eh bien ils étaient pêcheurs de poissons
et de perles aujourd'hui ils ont en
réserve 15 milliards de barils de
pétrole et son et troisième producteur
de gaz au monde
[Musique]
si le qatar le voisin de l'arabie
saoudite il en est pourtant bien loin
ici les femmes ont le permis de conduire
est long celui de travailler et la loi
ne leur impose pas de tenue particulière
la tradition elle si les qataris sont
musulmans leur loi est décrite dans le
coran c'est la charia quant à ce
monsieur il règne ici depuis 13 ans
c'est le cheikh hamad bin khalifa al
thani il a secoué le cocotier et tout
moderniser
[Musique]
ross
oh
[Musique]
c'est une maison typiquement qatari
auquel entré comme deuxième classe à ça
c'est le salon intérieur le majilis
essence est rejetée c'est pour montrer
que les femmes sont gâtées par leur mari
il faut que ça en jette pour montrer
qu'on est la plus gâtée candela mais
il ya un piano qui appartenait à
beethoven ah oui l'été à beethoven tu
veux le voir
la
statue this au pied nous a appartenu à
beethoven oui
mais il n'est pas accordée parce qu'il
est trop vieux
amis qatari aime collectionner le
principal étant les sabres pour les
mariages tradition
c'est un sabre qui date du 16e siècle
mon père l'a acheté trente mille dollars
il appartenait au fils de saladin
une des figures de l'islam ok
10 la piscine
c'était la belle vie 1
les tasses de thé avec le trap au qatari
qia pas de dire monsieur mais sinon ce
sont de vrais doutes entourent les
mondanités pour les réunions officielles
nous en avons avec les diamants
nous vivons dans le luxe vous avez bien
de la chance je ferai pareil tu sais
[Musique]
aucun d'entre vous de vos s'asseoir sur
son argent il se la couler douce non non
nous voulons faire quelque chose on se
regarde pas le nombril vous savez je dis
papa j'ai de l'argent je vais m'asseoir
tranquille me relaxer me mettre devant
la télé jusqu'à la fin de mes jours je
me demande tout le temps que puis-je
faire pour aider le pays d'ailleurs vous
savez c'est aussi le but du gouvernement
qatari il ya quelque chose qu'on appelle
la cata risation c'est essayer de
diriger les gens vers les études c'est
pour ne plus embaucher des étrangers
mais uniquement des qataris toccata nous
essayons vraiment d'être indépendant
dans notre pays il n'y a que 25 % de
qatari c'est très peu la population
immigrée au qatar c'est 75% de la
population
tubes et qu'être khaddari ce n'est pas
simplement être riche non ce n'est pas
que ça nous restons très proches de nos
traditions tout en modernisant pourquoi
pas parce que nous sommes fiers de nos
origines nous sommes fiers de nos
ancêtres fiers de notre histoire
la ligne entre tradition et modernité tu
vois et bien nous sommes au beau milieu
nous n'allons pas grandir en perdant de
vue nos racines mais d'un autre côté on
ne va pas vivre comme deux grands pères
et négligé de modernité
non nous sommes au milieu mais
[Musique]
qui s'émousse récemment
pendant ce temps à doha d'autres bolides
aquatique cela
[Musique]
élégance vitesse et grands moteurs
à
e
les hommes des hommes des hommes aucune
femme en vue voilà qui n'arrange pas du
tout les affaires
ok je pense aux tic
[Musique]
vous êtes le responsable ici
vous êtes très important parce que tout
le monde vient vous demander quelque
chose alors je vous demande quelque
chose aussi
je cherche une mère qatari aucun
explosif m'expliquer l'éducation qui est
donnée aux enfants ici c'est pour ça que
je n'ai pas une merde je peux en être
une vous vendez traîne je suis un père
et parfois j'ai le rôle de la mère très
souvent en fait
pourquoi pas vous êtes ma meilleure amie
à partir de maintenant
mohamad yusuf haji et d'un père de
quatre enfants surnom mg fonction
m'améliorer ni
mes enfants parce que j'aime en fait
que des trucs de moon
je veux faire du vélo j'aime faire du
quad
allé dans le désert chaud avec en photo
donc ils sont pourris gâtés non ils
partagent nos hobbies wheels on pourrait
regretter
[Musique]
je m'adresse maintenant à tous les
enfants qui vous regardent et leurs
parents en leur disant et papa mais
maman pourquoi moi aussi je n'ai pas mon
quad et bien mon petit gars c'est à toi
que je m'adresse c'est parce que tu n'es
pas qataris open de get one world
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
ici
à cette époque de l'année et les arts ea
berne donc il reste là tout l'hiver
[Musique]
tu vois ça blackrock c'est une crotte de
lézards les très vieilles manuscrits
sont plus rien
avec une bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle
pour l'utiliser pour faire du tu veux
dire avant il faisait du feu avec sa
très bon pour démarrer ainsi
comment tu sais tout ça
faisait mon père me l'a expliqué
maintenant je l'expliqué aux enfants
et j'espère qu'ils s'en souviendront
pour l'expliquer aux leurs
vraiment
nul n'oubliera pas mais je voulais
toujours tous mes jeux tu vas pas oublié
moi je vais oublier demain
expliquent ils parlent toujours en
anglais avec tes enfants
anglais arabe aussi tu sais c'est
vraiment très difficile d'entendre
quelqu'un parler arabe ici tout le monde
parle si bien anglais
[Musique]
à
l'époque il avait une coupure
il utilise une fourmi une grosse fourmi
il recevait la blessure laissez-les info
me mordre sa
voie celle ci mort
qui prend le corps tu te tournes non
mais maintenant ça tient fort
sans papa
et elle reste tu peux en mettre autant
que tu veux
c'est une grosse coupure tueur mai 10 20
graff et tout le long et ça reste
combien de temps ça reste pendant des
jours une semaine deux semaines c'est
juste que mon devoir est super moche
[Musique]
et
oh
oui
ces jeunes gens en uniforme font partie
de la qatar leadership academy l'école
qui forme les leaders de demain
[Musique]
salut
les instructions de la journée et si une
équipe d'al jazeera c'est le jour
autoroutes
pour faire partie de cette académie
quelques critères sont requis financier
d'abord 10000 euros par mois pour
inscrire son petit qui doit être garçon
bien sûr de langue maternelle arabe et
musulman de confession
tiens justement ce monsieur qui embrasse
à la qatari son élève ses khalid
mohammed muftah professeur de coran
[Musique]
quand vous lisez le coran vous devez
suivre les règles
vous leur apprenez à ne chanter
correctement
[Musique]
semaine
allant du lilas
[Musique]
alors le professeur me table mais les
élèves sont ils à la hauteur ubu interro
surprise
hawat et à partir de quel âge vous
pouvez faire le pèlerinage tu es
responsable de tes péchés de tes bonnes
actions à l'âge de 10 ans dieu te donne
punition et récompenses à partir de 7 h
10 ans donc tu peux faire le pèlerinage
à partir de 10 ans qui peut m'expliquer
pourquoi vous prier cinq fois par jour
d'abord le prophète est allé voir dieu
qui lui a dit prix 50 fois par jour le
prophète a dit c'est trop dur pour les
humains et petit à petit dieu est
descendu à 5 fois
la première prière est à 4 heures avant
le lever du soleil tu le fais vraiment
tu te lève à 4 heures du matin ça oui
certains le font d'autres ne le font pas
on n'est pas parfait
si on ne se lève pas ont pris quand on
se réveille
am je comprends en fait vous êtes
supposé le faire à quatre heures avant
le lever du soleil mais si vous vous
réveillez à 10h vous le faites à 10
heures
ok
je crois que ces mots ce qu'est la
montée du cours se pacifier la moitié du
cours à la mosquée
[Musique]
à
car son vol privé mais dans leur coeur
les parterres cela est très
sage
quelle est la place de la famille dans
la foi musulmane
il existe de très nombreuses
recommandations dans le coran à propos
de la famille
par exemple comment l'homme va choisir
sa femme
comment il va se marier
comment va-t-il
comment ça s'appelle déjà quel contrat
quel contrat de mariage va-t-il choisir
et beaucoup d'autres choses
parfois le coran parle de détails
par exemple comment l'homme peut et doit
dormir avec sa femme comment il peut
vivre avec elle
est-ce qu'ils parlent des punitions pour
les enfants s'ils se comportent mal
oui le coran nous dit qu'il faut
respecter nos parents qu'il faut être
gentil avec eux est toujours écouter ce
qu'ils disent enfin parfois les parents
sont vraiment ennuyeux nous oui mais tu
dois être un bon musulman mais personne
n'est parfait c'est vrai il ya une
différence entre être musulman et être
croyant le croyant doit prier écouter
ses parents le musulman c'est juste un
musulman
et à propos de vos frères et soeurs le
coran parle en la famille c'est très
fort s'ils sont plus grands tu dois les
respecter et s'ils sont plus petit il
faut les chercher
et les punitions
quand tu as dix ans si tu ne prit pas
ton père dois te battre pour que tu
pries
mais pas trop fort non juste comme ça
sur la main qu'à se battre trop fort ce
n'est pas permis personne ne peut te
frapper sur le visage c'est interdit le
prophète l'a dit c'est interdit
mon truc ton label c'est grave si cette
hausse pour le
statut désolé vous priez j'aime avec les
femmes de toute façon
n'importe quoi quiz qui vous éduquer vos
parents ou le coran
les deux nos parents apprennent dans le
coran et nous apprennent à leur tour en
nous racontant les histoires du prophète
le conflit entre votre vie et le coran
je veux dire vous pouvez regarder un
petit musique nous jeter le jour et être
musulman
le prof nous voir regarder ça c'est vrai
que ça va énerver elle aussi nous avons
les ordinateurs sur lesquels nous
écoutons de la musique mais quand le
prof arrive nous éteignons parce que
vous savez c'est bon on écoute quand
même
[Musique]
d'octobre nous je vous présente le
docteur bruno qui mieux qu'un suisse
pour diriger cette académie
alors ce que vous voyez là c'est une
chambre de 4 le matin ils font leur lit
eux mêmes pas vraiment dans leurs
habitudes moi je le faisais au carré oui
ça c'est un autre style je le faisais
aussi à l'armée comme ça mais là c'est
plus joli et puis c'est passé difficile
et puis bon je vous rappelle que ici on
n'est pas dans un camp militaire
je n'étais pas dans un camp militaire
j'étais chez les dominicaines
encore
plus la société est riche plus les
jeunes sont gâtés
et en plus ici plus qu'ailleurs parce
que comme je vous le disais ils sont
passés assez brutalement du chameau à la
cadillac d'un coup d'un seul mais
maintenant les parents réalisent et ils
se disent qu'il faut peut-être faire
attention à la prochaine génération la
faire changer parce que c'est pas bon
pour les enfants que tout soit fait par
leur bonne
qu'ils aient déjà leur propre voiture
qui ne soit pas obligé de faire des
études puisque ils reprendront la
société de papa en fait ça marche pas
comme ça
et pour les éduquer ses enfants ne
recule devant rien on dépense sans
compter y compris en matière de télé al
jazeera children's channel
la chaîne qatarie pour enfants qui
s'adresse en fait à 22 pays arabes soit
20 à 30 millions d'enfants par jour
[Musique]
duplex entre otura au qatar
et
si cette chaîne existe c'est aussi parce
que les enfants du monde arabe quand il
allume la télé il y voit plus souvent la
guerre que des dessins lui aujourd'hui
si vous regardez les chaînes info qui
diffuse à longueur de journée dans des
foyers arabes l'enfant arabe ne regarde
pas la même chose qu'un enfant français
ou un enfant allemand ou un enfant
américain donc quand vous regardez ce
qui se passe en palestine en irak en
somalie au soudan et ailleurs si on
ajoute à cela le manque de démocratie de
liberté
la pauvreté l'émigration donc tous ces
facteurs là font que nous devons avoir
un contenu qui est ciblé mais qui reste
enfants parce qu'un enfant quand il
s'assoit devant la tv c'est d'abord pour
s'amuser sait jamais pour apprendre
[Musique]
est-ce que les tabous de la chaîne
jeunesse du monde arabe sont les mêmes
que les nôtres sur ce plateau ici on a
traité les écoles coraniques ont à
traiter l'éducation religieuse à l'école
on a traité les abus sexuels on a traité
du travail des enfants on a traité même
d'un sujet qui a provoqué un tonnerre
dans la presse locale qui était la
mixité oui
donc quand on traite la mixité ici on
est exposé à des opinions est ce que la
chaîne et pour la mixité elle est contre
la mixité nous nous sommes ni pour ni
contre
l'américaine pas de dessin animé
japonais ainsi aux mains du dessin animé
japonais bon tout à fait ah bon mais
n'oubliez pas il ya des milliers
d'heures de dessins animés japonais qui
sont de l'animation
ludo-éducatif pas une faune des deux
côtés d'accord c'est pas ça le coca et
alors
ou bien sur un pont que la jauge
d'essence c'est vraiment mais
très basse un quasi vide et nous avons
failli tomber en panne d'essence au
qatar
moissac ou tristes ans quand tu fais un
plein en france
et le litre et doit être un euro et plus
un euro et plus values
[Musique]
8 heures
un match de gala
la semaine que derrière ces vénérables
bondira n'égale un réal
quand on fait le plein à la maison en
france on mais on va dire environ 50
libre pour 60 euros si vous posiez le
plein ici avec votre petite voiture où
étaient 58 travaux coûteraient
[Musique]
8 euros
ils seront 60 euros 8 euros 8 euros
j'ai pas assez petit pour payer
[Musique]
si les petits bouts du monde sont venus
se promener au qatar ce n'est pas par
hasard évidemment l'éducation aussi
c'est un chantier majeur le cheikh a
décidé l'émir a décidé de créer le
conseil suprême de l'éducation il ya
également un ministère de l'éducation
dans lesquels on va se rendre maintenant
pour rencontrer s'il vous plaît madame
la ministre
madame ministre mais également
secrétaire général du conseil suprême de
l'éducation
votre excellence je suis ici depuis deux
semaines déjà et j'ai vu combien longe
sur l'éducation est majeur expliquez-moi
pourquoi riz
en dehors de l'apprentissage de la
lecture et de l'écriture
l'éducation apporte aussi aux enfants le
sens du dialogue
l'accomplissement de soi l'ouverture aux
autres la nakba notre pays traverse une
période de changement énorme et demi
nous développons nos savoir faire dans
tous les domaines et nous avons besoin
dans un avenir proche de nos enfants
pour qu'ils encadrent et conduisent le
développement et les progrès de ce pays
donc je crains
les parents sont aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus conscients des enjeux de
l'éducation il y accorde une très grande
importance doucement
le rôle au sein des écoles est plus
important ils ont un droit de regard sur
l'enseignement dispensé à leurs enfants
la prise de conscience des femmes y en a
beaucoup évolué en ce qui concerne
l'école
ah oui madame la ministre vous avez
parfaitement raison et l'ajustement nous
avons rendez-vous dans l'école des
enfants dng une école anglaise privée et
mixte
[Musique]
dans la classe d'amener leurs sujets de
travail cette semaine ce sont les
animaux
[Musique]
vraiment leur présenter des animaux
notre pays nos formes est déchaîné
ce qu'on trouve dans le désert
est ce que c'est bien que les enfants
connaissent les animaux du coin
[Musique]
d'où vient-il les enfants du monde
entier
face ya une chose à prendre en compte
ici c'est tellement évident quand vous
arrivez non non et 2 s'est créé enfants
du qatari avec les autres nationalités
depuis tout petit jusqu'à ce qu'ils
deviennent adultes y sait jamais une
communité seul jamais jamais jamais
grandissent avec les autres civils avec
les autres ils ont les moyens d'aller à
l'étranger
c'est
une des particularités les enfants
qatari cette carte
visa
[Musique]
vous souvenez de quelle race et ce
faucon
la dernière fois je vous le dis
oui c'est un rapace
maintenant si vous êtes sages je vais
enlever la cagoule du faucon hockey
comme ça vous pourrez voir c'est sûr
d'abord je soulève en lui la cagoule
pour enlever la cagoule
[Musique]
tu tires sur la ficelle
sésame et
les young boys d'un jeune oiseau il
harmonise savez combien de temps ils
vivent 30
[Musique]
25 à 30
quand il a un an il est déjà adulte
n'ayez pas peur il calme
n'est pas peur à qui le tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les parents ils viennent tous comme
toi à l'école ou bien tu as vraiment
exceptionnel non mais aussi
contre exemple ces jeunes gens ont 18
ans et leurs parents n'ont pas été
conscient de l'importance de l'école ou
non pas du tout fait d'études
inacceptable pour l'état qui veille et
charge le centre social de développement
de les remettre à niveau puis de leur
trouver un travail
aujourd'hui l'entreprise dolphin energy
va tenter de les motiver à travailler
pour eux mais pour ce faire il faudrait
qu'il arrive à se comprendre écoutez
bien monsieur il parle en anglais
c'est
c
vous pouvez traduire
dit les en arabe
vous voulez que je fasse
c'est surréaliste
pourquoi est ce monsieur qui parlent
qu'anglais qui comprennent pas vous qui
devait traduire
c'est sûr
nous espérons qu'il soit la dernière
génération à sortir de l'école sans un
très haut niveau d'éducation
le travail du centre social de
développement cdd cela les derniers ils
sont au bord de la route et nous tentons
de les raccrocher aux trains
ils dakhla si ils sont restés au bord de
la route ça n'était pas à cause d'une
question d'argent non non c'était leurs
parents
parce que leurs parents n'avaient pas
compris l'enjeu et l'importance de
l'éducation
ils nous voient comme une boîte survie
bo3
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de qualification
ils viennent juste de passer leur
diplôme
ils n'ont pas le même niveau que les
autres en tout cas
et c'est ce que nous tentons de change
et développer leur donner de l'aide leur
donner des forces
ça veut dire que ici au qatar si tu n'as
pas le même niveau que les autres
le gouvernement te pousse vers le haut
tout chaud oui exactement
incroyable
alors maintenant vous penser très fort à
votre petit dernier celui qui ne fait
rien à l'école aux qataris auraient reçu
avec considération et tous les zones
rouges pas avec le code il ya un petit
péché qui est prévue pour après a lu ces
dates
fauchée quelques framboises de saison
qu'est-ce
qu'elle a tu m'as tu sais je n'arrive
pas à imaginer la même chose en france
ça rentre pas dans la tête
ce n'est pas du tout la même culture
mais tu peux m'expliquer je pense que tu
es en plein choc de culture gay ou idiot
mais tu veut bien m'expliquer pourquoi
ils sont occupe autant parce qu'ils sont
l'avenir de ses enfants sont les enfants
de ce pays
ils sont l'avenir
et c'est bien entendu parce qu'ils sont
peu nombreux et que ce pays est très
riche qu'un tel système est possible
mais vous n'êtes pas au bout de vos
surprises le simple fait de n'être
qatari vous garrouty l'éducation la
santé l'eau et l'électricité gratuite
tous les services publics gratuits
un prêt de plus de 100000 euros à
seulement 1 pour son intérêt pour
construire votre maison sur un terrain
gratuit
quant au très bon élève l'état offre à
tout ce qui arrive à un certain niveau d
études supérieures dans n'importe quelle
université du monde
enfin il me reste à vous dire qu'elle
qatari ne paye jamais d'impôts alors
j'essaie là on regarde tous de ne pas
être née qataris ça et bien vous mais
vous non on n'a rien en fait c'est
nantes
je sais ce qu'est le sport national ici
c'est le portable
le sport national et le shopping aller
dans les moules les hommes les femmes
les garçons les filles les ados
en fait c'est pas vraiment du shopping
ces marchés dans le moule et tourner
tourner
[Musique]
ma maman et qu'est ce que fait une fille
wettre qu'elle fait cherche des fringues
bien sûr c'est ce que je vais faire
les deux pitchounette qui rigole
je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai quand
même assez envie de lanmodez si elle
veut bien me guider dans le monde de la
bahia
que les filles à l'outsourcing
vous attendez votre premier à bahia
d'habitude on va l'acheter en famille et
avec nos cousines notre maire les
membres de ta famille féminine et puis
voiture choisie une qui te plaît en fait
elle qui nous guide dans le choix de la
bonne à banias il ya en fait des règles
pas très fair et peut-être de détails
mais c'est une joie d'avoir la première
à bayard oui oui c'était mon choix je le
voulais
je le voulais tu n'es pas obligé tu le
souhaites oui je le voulais oui tu n'es
pas obligé de porter la meilleure c'est
ton choix
la bahia ça t'apporte du résumé ce pacte
légende ouvre les portes les gens te
respecte il te parle comme à quelqu'un
d'important à qui il donne de la valeur
si tu le portes pas ton à bahia tu n'es
qu'une enfant et puis aussi cela
t'apporte beaucoup de liberté tellement
de liberté
par exemple tu dois sortir tu es en
retard est tu n'es pas prête tu mets
n'importe quoi sur toi et c'est bon ok
personne ne le sait
ma cousine va l'université en pyjama
avec son abaya par-dessus
hockey ici tu mets un pyjama dessous tu
peux aussi m
une mini jupe
non non non non c'est inapproprié mais
en même temps personne ne saurait et
personne ne réaliserai non non non c'est
pas possible rien du tout c'est pas
possible enfin après tout si c'est
confortable pour toi c'est ton choix
mais tu dis pas aux gens que tu es en
train de faire ça non peut-être
peut-être certaines fortes en sous
vêtements peut-être sinon bien sûr que
c'est fatigant annonçant on sait pas
tu parles ok you're the one
et ouais est trop sage les filles vous
avez quinze ans c'est pas drôle
mais si c'est tellement tu peux acheter
une abaya que tu as sorti à tes
vêtements à tes chaussures c'est comme
acheter des vêtements mais c'est
toujours noir
n'ont regardé j'ai des couleurs
et mafieuses
elles sont assorties à mes chaussures
code beaucoup de choses
dont ça va les filles est-ce que vous
pouvez aller au cinéma avec des copains
tu as you like non
copains j'ai dit
si je marche maintenant avec un garçon
même si c'est mon cousin les gens vont
penser travers
mais située dans un groupe avec tes
cousine tes cousins et que le groupe est
grand et qu'il y a des gens plus âgés là
il n'y a pas de problème un fils j ai
rêvé rêvé des garçons bull fait
si c'est comme si tu prends un très bon
garçon on va se dire entre nous waouh il
est grand mais pas plus que ça semak
limites
des rêves au personne ne peut les
arrêter et quand fatima a fini son
shopping elle va à l'école école privée
pas de voile obligé
good cité
et puis enseignement dans
au top
[Musique]
air connu cette jeune femme vient de
passer vous emmène en classe prépa
reconnaît fatima l'abaya venez on va
prendre un cours d'arabe
vous avez remarqué qu'ici tout le monde
parle parfaitement l'anglais mais
l'arabe c'est une autre paire de manches
et comment est ce qu'on dit pain en irak
et dans le golfe rome un
nombre aussi c'est une autre forme
ce sont différentes manières de dire par
dans différents pays mais tu veux dire
en arabe oui vous n'utilisez pas le même
mot dans la raab officiel si c'est le
même mot mais dans les différents pays
il ya différents dialectes
ça veut dire que tu dois apprendre la
langue qu'ils parlent maintenant
nous l'apprenons des tout-petits
automatiquement comme ça nous le savons
très vite et nous apprenons aussi des
mots des autres pays
[Musique]
quelle est ta langue maternelle
qatari
mais je parle aussi l'arabe classique
du montât langue maternelle c'est le
qatari si tu étais né j'y prenne langue
maternelle ce serait alors l'égyptien
c'est pas l'arabe classique mais tout le
monde parle l'arabe classique qui est le
même partout
il existe des arabes qui ne parlent pas
l'arabe classique c'est un désastre pour
eux car l'arabe classique est la langue
du coran et ils ne peuvent pas le
comprendre
alors que les gens doivent comprendre
s'il vous plaît j'ai une question d'où
vient l'arabe classique de classe et de
quel pays oui tu crains tu mon
oreille
ça vient de la tribu des corail en
arabie saoudite et dans la péninsule
arabique à la mecque
la nation arabe la nation arabe les
racines viennent du yémen des pays de la
péninsule arabique l'arabe est né dans
ces endroits
après ses cours fatima se rend parfois
dans une grande chose de son papa c'est
ce monsieur là non pas lui l'huile son
ranch il est dans le désert 20 minutes
de doha mais aujourd'hui fatima n'est
pas là parce que nous sommes jeudi ma le
jeudi c'est le jour des hommes le ranch
est réservé aux garçons
[Musique]
combien d'enfants 8 3 filles et cinq
garçons
[Musique]
abdallah l'optique insupportable dans
tintin au pays de l'or noir vous
souvenez massé lui
[Musique]
sur un projet avec son chèche autant
c'est comme ça c'est moi même
[Musique]
il faut toujours que je le fasse moi
même été trop bête pour le faire tout
seul
[Musique]
c'est joli
[Rires]
c'est pas facile à notre qatari
c'est pas facile
c'est fini
ok
il n'a pas la langue dans sa poche celui
là
pas trop serré je peux y aller d'accord
pour jouer à patienter un peu
il est content il est très content
vous êtes sévère avec les enfants je
vous ai vu
non non je suis très sévère mais là je
suis cool parce que vous êtes là
le pénis est souvent
souvent la maison
où sa mère et lui cède il veut une
mobylette les mobylettes devait achever
à lille un cheval mais quel genre de
punition vous allez donner
je pars en bateau pour aller en mer ou
pc je n'emmène pas
le laisser à la maison les jusqu'au
lendemain
il recommence toujours toujours
d une canaille papa j'ai un problème
regardez regardez
chercher les ennuis
sautons maintenant une génération car
les plus grands aussi où leur animal de
compagnie
que le carreau
ramsey dans le désert dans un 4 4
avec un faucon qui doit dîner
à bord
il dit
poulet au menu du faucon ce soir est
très gentiment regarde les morts de rire
il nous fait remarquer que
le qatar va manger l'emblème de la
france
à table
[Musique]
patent petit poulet
il ya beaucoup de pays qui essaie de
garder leurs traditions et qui avance
mais comme ici j'ai jamais vu ça vous
avez on est au beau milieu du désert on
entend un téléphone portable et des 4 4
il ya des ingénieurs qui sont en train
de nourrir un faucon avec un poulet
c'est un sacré moment les magnifiques ce
faucon il est magnifique
oui
à quel âge tu as fait ça pour la
première fois
seize ans quand je puis qui rentrait de
france parce que là bas je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion
tu m'étonnes le faucon a donc chassé le
poulet mais mes amis lui ont réservé une
surprise les colombes c'est bien plus
digeste mais s'est envolé donc j'ai
adopté la méthode qatari et je cours
après la colombe dans le désert
[Musique]
et comme dans ces histoires des mille et
une nuits qui ne finissent jamais après
avoir fait du cheval chasser avec un
faucon il est temps maintenant de
rejoindre le majilis la tente familiale
traditionnelle qatari installé au milieu
du désert à quelques kilomètres du ranch
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la clé dans la tente
[Rires]
c'est pas à l'ancienne 6 mai s'est
modernisé
puisque série fate
à toi je peux pas le croire vous êtes le
parrain
allô
c'est moi j'y allais
enfin m
what did you ou avez vous voyagez dans
toute votre vie vous êtes vous allé
le liban
la turquie
l'egypte au maroc
par toulon golf
hériot thaïlande c'est d'habitude les
enfants voyagent pas autant que vous
il faut beaucoup d'argent pour faire ça
nous avons pétrole le gaz la plus grande
réserve et si tu en avais plus vous
qu'est-ce que tu ferais nour on
mangerait des dates
boirait du lait de chamelle
[Musique]
comment avons-nous survécu avant le
pétrole il pourrait lui survivre alors
oui nous avons survécu pendant des
milliers d'années si vous regardez
comment nos ancêtres ont vécu ça ne nous
inquiète pas il n'y avait rien ici
et ils ont survécu mais vous êtes
capable de retourner à cette ville
oui d'ailleurs nous leur apprenons à
survivre dans le désert je les prends et
je les laisse tout seul et je m'en vais
dans le désert à quel âge à quatre ou
six ans gelé les seuls et je m'en vais
combien de temps sans électricité 6h
6h30
faut leur apprendre à vivre c'est ça la
ville
et les filles
non les filles pour nous ce sont des
princesses
[Musique]
mais tout le monde est il aussi relax et
détendu à propos de la disparition
annoncée du pétrole
[Musique]
nous inquiétons tous pour nous
et nous sommes dans un pays qui a des
plans pour l'avenir qui travaillent sur
des projets
[Musique]
fait le pétrole dans quinze ans c'est
fini est ce qu il ya de grandes chances
que vous utilisez d'autres énergies
quoi qu'il arrive nous ferons partie le
monde
tamim miche
youssef
c'est avec l'argent du pétrole et du gaz
que le qatar financent leurs études que
se passera-t-il quand il n'y aura plus
de pétrole et quand nous n'aurons plus
besoin du gaz eh bien les qatari seront
prêts à vivre autrement parce qu'ils
auront fini ils élever leurs enfants
inchallah si dieu le veut
non excuse moi tu veux bien tout arrêter
là
non parce que j'ai complètement oublié
de vous dire mais les dollars même par
milliers au qatar comme ailleurs ne sont
d'aucune utilité contre la conscience de
l'adolescence
c'est le sport préféré des jeunes
garçons qui s'ennuient
non non non non non
[Rires]
comme
c'est notre cas
[Rires]
d'accord le cas des scores le score
équilibré c'est à dire toi les quatre
hommes et quatre roues sont bien
équilibrées que la voiture est bien fait
pour sa gueule
[Rires]
tapée dans sa voiture
marie
tous les bars y sont fermées
marianne2 qu'ils aient
à la queen peut-être ok j'aurais pu
demander c'est très joli
parce que smith à watts et lifan inside
the sisterhood
y figurent
je veux ce pas j'ai des chaussettes
jaunes
j'ai acheté ici je trouve génial
allez hop ici on est en plein milieu de
l'eau
[Musique]